For the past week, protesters have filled the streets of cities and towns across the United States and even in some locations abroad. People from across the political spectrum of all races, ages, and backgrounds are joining in, demanding an end to racism in response to the police killing of George Floyd in Minneapolis. Major companies are posting messages of support for racial equality, and while some demonstrations have been marred by violence and looting, most of the protests and protesters are peaceful. Why is this happening right now? What has made this moment ripe for collective action on this scale?
在过去的一周里，抗议者挤满了美国各地城镇的街道，甚至在国外的一些地方也是如此。来自不同政治派别、各种族、各年龄段和各背景的人们纷纷加入其中，以回应明尼阿波利斯市警察杀害乔治·弗洛伊德的事件，要求结束种族主义。大型企业纷纷发布支持种族平等的声明，虽然一些示威活动受到暴力和抢劫的影响，但大多数抗议活动和抗议者都是和平的。为什么现在会发生这种情况？是什么让这一时刻成为大规模集体行动的成熟时机？
What are the psychological forces that are driving people, even in the midst of the COVID-19 pandemic, to turn out in such numbers and in so many places? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that looks at the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. I'm speaking today with Dr. Lauren Duncan, a professor of psychologist. at Smith College, who studies what motivates some people to try to change society, while others are happy with the status quo. While she didn't exactly write the book on the psychology of collective action, she did write the chapter of that name for the Oxford Handbook of Personality and Social Psychology. Her research digs into the reasons why people act on their political
即使在新冠疫情期间，是什么样的心理力量驱使人们以如此庞大的规模和在如此多的地方走上街头？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我采访的是史密斯学院的心理学教授劳伦·邓肯博士，她研究的是什么激励了一些人试图改变社会，而另一些人却对现状感到满意。虽然她并没有确切地写过关于集体行动心理学的书，但她确实为《牛津人格与社会心理学手册》撰写了同名章节。她的研究深入探讨了人们采取政治行动的原因，
beliefs looking at internal factors like personality and external factors such as current events. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Duncan. Thank you very much, Kim. Let's start by talking about what's happening today that's driving people into the street in great numbers and not just in big cities, but in small towns and overseas. And let's be honest. We see injustices in the world every day, but rarely have we seen protests quite like what we're seeing now. So what's different about today? Well, I have been talking with friends and we've been talking about the concept of tipping point. anytime there's any sort of meaningful social change, there comes a tipping point where people who have been oppressed or treated unfairly or treated with violence in years and years and years have been protesting against it for years.
审视了诸如人格等内在因素以及时事等外在因素。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，邓肯博士。非常感谢，金。让我们从谈论今天发生的事情开始，是什么驱使人们大量走上街头，不仅是在大城市，而且是在小城镇和海外。老实说，我们每天都在世界上看到不公正现象，但我们很少看到像现在这样规模的抗议活动。那么今天有什么不同呢？嗯，我一直在和朋友们讨论“临界点”这个概念。每当出现任何有意义的社会变革时，都会出现一个临界点，那些多年来一直受到压迫、不公平对待或暴力对待的人们，多年来一直在对此进行抗议。
But it's only when the, quote, silent majority people who aren't actually directly affected by this maltreatment. It's only when those people finally take an interest and start to get outraged, that that causes the things to tip over into wide-scale social change. So you're asking about why are there so many protests right now? Well, I mean, obviously we have these events that so many instances of. innocent or black people getting treated violently by police. And that's been going on for a long time. You're saying what's different now. And there are a couple of things that are different right now. I would say the pandemic is actually one of the contributing factors. There are a lot of people who have been cooped up inside their houses for two months to three months. And some of them have lost
但只有当所谓的“沉默的大多数”——那些并没有直接受到这种虐待影响的人——最终产生兴趣并开始感到愤怒时，才会促使事情向大规模的社会变革倾斜。所以你问为什么现在有这么多抗议活动？嗯，我的意思是，显然我们有这些事件，有太多无辜的黑人被警察暴力对待的例子。这种情况已经持续很长时间了。你问现在有什么不同。目前确实有几点不同。我认为疫情实际上是促成因素之一。有很多人被关在家里两到三个月了。他们中的一些人失去了
their jobs. They have a lot more time to be consuming social media, to be watching TV, to be up on political events. The fact that nowadays, everybody has a phone that has a camera on it means, and we also have many social media platforms, means that many people are direct witnesses to protests, to Not just the events that spur the protests, but the protests themselves. And for example, we've been seeing a lot on social media police reaction to peaceful protests. And that has also fueled these continuing protests. So the fact that people all have cameras, we're able to see these vivid visual images of unjust treatment. They get posted on social media.
工作。他们有更多的时间来使用社交媒体、看电视、关注政治事件。如今每个人都有一部带摄像头的手机，这意味着——而且我们还有许多社交媒体平台——意味着许多人是抗议活动的直接见证者，不仅是那些引发抗议的事件，还有抗议活动本身。例如，我们在社交媒体上看到了很多警察对和平抗议活动的反应。这也助长了这些持续不断的抗议活动。所以，人们都有摄像头，我们能够看到这些关于不公正待遇的生动视觉图像。它们被发布在社交媒体上。
social media is one of the best ways to reach millions of people. So it spreads like wildfire. So we have these distribution channels for amateur videos that is unprecedented. So we've got the pandemic where people have more flexible time and also the availability of avenues in which to post videos and to share information and to to analyze what's going on from a structural point of view, that's all been very important. I would also say in terms of the pandemic, I've heard a lot of talk about and read articles about how the pandemic is spurring a lot of people to think about what's really important in life. And so for people who have been kind of just caught up in the daily grind for years
社交媒体是接触数百万人的最佳方式之一。所以它像野火一样蔓延。因此，我们拥有这些前所未有的业余视频分发渠道。所以我们有疫情，人们有更灵活的时间，也有发布视频、分享信息以及从结构角度分析正在发生的事情的渠道，这些都非常重要。关于疫情，我还听到很多讨论，也读过一些文章，谈到疫情是如何促使许多人思考生活中真正重要的是什么。对于那些多年来一直陷入日常琐事的人来说，
and years and years or months and months and months, going to their jobs, taking care of their kids, going to school, whatever, and basically saying, I don't really have time to engage with what's going on outside of my neighborhood, because for a lot of these people, this is outside their neighborhood. Now they're sitting at home, they're with their families, and a lot of people are reevaluating what is important in life. And so people are. are saying, I see these things on social media. That is a really vivid image that is so unfair. And who am I as a person? I need to take a stand. And there are many ways to take stands and they're widely available. Social media makes lots of ways to donate money or to even do things like
几个月又几个月，去上班、照顾孩子、上学等等，基本上说，我真的没有时间去参与社区之外发生的事情，因为对他们中的许多人来说，这是社区之外的事情。现在他们坐在家里，和家人在一起，许多人正在重新评估生活中什么是重要的。所以人们在说，我在社交媒体上看到了这些事情。那是一个非常生动的画面，太不公平了。作为一个人的我，是谁？我需要表明立场。表明立场的方式有很多，而且随处可见。社交媒体提供了许多捐款甚至做一些事情的方式，比如
just kind of click a like or repost things. There are many low-cost ways for people to protest. Then there's also, you know, in towns, cities across this country and in other countries, there are protests being organized daily. And so it's very easy to find a way to engage in this particular set of protests right now. Your work posits a model that shows two distinct roots to collective action. Can you talk about what they are and how. they're playing into the protests that we're seeing right now? Sure.
只是点个赞或转发。人们抗议的方式有很多低成本的选择。此外，你知道，在这个国家的城镇、城市以及其他国家，每天都有抗议活动在组织。所以现在找到一种参与这组特定抗议活动的方式非常容易。你的工作提出了一个模型，展示了集体行动的两条不同路径。你能谈谈它们是什么以及它们是如何在目前我们看到的抗议活动中发挥作用的吗？当然。
So in my model, we talk about the fact that there might be collective action that is taken. And the distinction is really, they're called movements of crisis and movements of conscience. In times of crisis, immediate reaction to maybe a killing or some sort of violence, people may react to what just happened in kind of a disorganized way without any articulated political analysis of what's going on. And so the classic example of that are riots that, you know, the Watts riots or the Los Angeles, what happened after Rodney King was acquitted in 1992, not Rodney King, the four white police officers who had beaten
在我的模型中，我们谈到了可能采取的集体行动。区别在于，它们被称为“危机运动”和“良知运动”。在危机时期，对杀戮或某种暴力行为的直接反应，人们可能会以一种无组织的方式对刚刚发生的事情做出反应，而没有任何对正在发生的事情的明确政治分析。这种运动的典型例子是骚乱，你知道，瓦茨骚乱，或者1992年罗德尼·金被判无罪后洛杉矶发生的事情，不是罗德尼·金，而是那四名殴打
King. Exactly. Yeah. So after, so when the, when the, when those four white police officers were acquitted of, of any wrongdoing in the beating of Rodney King, there were, there was a response from central Los Angeles communities of color. And that involved some violence or, you know, destruction of property, et cetera. but you wouldn't necessarily say there was a diffuse feeling of anger. There's a feeling of anger. Things aren't right, but there wasn't necessarily an articulated political analysis of this is exactly what needs to change.
金的白人警察。没错。是的。所以，当那四名白人警察在殴打罗德尼·金的案件中被判无罪时，洛杉矶市中心的有色人种社区做出了反应。这涉及一些暴力或财产破坏等。但你不一定能说当时有一种弥漫的愤怒感。确实有一种愤怒感。事情不对劲，但并不一定有明确的政治分析，说明到底需要改变什么。
It was just kind of this frustration people were acting out. But then you have crisis of conscience, which tends to happen in times where basic human needs are met and people are agitating for rights. So, you know, the women's movement is a classic example of this. Women have been agitating for equal rights for hundreds of years. And usually what happens for women's movements is, you know, you don't typically have kind of basically what you have is people who develop an analysis of the situation. They recognize sexism and they recognize things that are unfair. and then they take action that is very strategic and thought out about how we want to change things. What's interesting about this particular set of protests right now is it seems to be a combination of the two.
这只是一种人们发泄出来的挫败感。但随后你有“良知危机”，这往往发生在基本人类需求得到满足、人们为权利而奔走的时候。所以，你知道，妇女运动就是一个典型的例子。妇女几百年来一直在为平等权利而奔走。通常妇女运动发生的情况是，你通常不会有——基本上你拥有的是那些对局势进行分析的人。她们认识到性别歧视，认识到不公平的事情，然后她们采取非常战略性和深思熟虑的行动，关于我们想要如何改变事情。这组特定抗议活动有趣的地方在于，它似乎是两者的结合。
So there is a very sophisticated political analysis about institutional racism and about how police office, the kind of police state or, structural, the way police officers are socialized, how that has to change. So there's a sophisticated analysis about that. But there's also this sense of kind of diffuse anger, particularly in communities of color, that we can't lose another life. We can't lose another life. So it's kind of a combination of the two. But what's interesting is oftentimes when people go to a protest because they have this feeling of anger and they're not really sure what to do about it. When they go to a protest, they often then develop, they're exposed to the sophisticated political analysis that ends up sustaining long-term activism. So something like, say, the Women's March right after the election of Donald Trump, that seemed very diffused like there really wasn't a clear agenda.
所以，对于制度性种族主义，以及警察机构、警察国家或警察社会化的方式，如何必须改变，有着非常复杂的政治分析。所以对此有复杂的分析。但也有这种弥漫的愤怒感，特别是在有色人种社区，我们不能再失去另一个生命了。我们不能再失去另一个生命了。所以这有点像两者的结合。但有趣的是，通常当人们因为这种愤怒感而去参加抗议，却不确定该怎么做时。当他们去参加抗议时，他们往往会接触到复杂的政治分析，最终维持了长期的行动主义。所以，比如唐纳德·特朗普当选后的“妇女大游行”，看起来非常分散，似乎真的没有明确的议程。
Is that why that seems to have fizzled out? Well, I think, yeah, that definitely is an example of, that's another example of because that move, because women's rights have been a movement for so long, that was a combination of both again. So there were a lot of people who had never participated in protests before who attended the marches right after Trump was elected because right after he was inaugurated, because, They were just feeling so hopeless and that they needed to be around people who felt the same way they did. And a lot of young people who didn't have any sophisticated analysis of this. They just knew they didn't like this fact that Trump got elected. So they were there. But there were also, there were so many different groups that went to these marches.
这就是它似乎逐渐平息的原因吗？嗯，我想，是的，这绝对是一个例子，因为那场运动，因为妇女权利运动已经存在了这么久，那又是两者的结合。所以有很多以前从未参加过抗议的人，在特朗普当选后参加了游行，因为在他就职后，他们只是感到非常绝望，他们需要和那些有同样感受的人在一起。很多年轻人对这一切没有任何复杂的分析。他们只是知道他们不喜欢特朗普当选这个事实。所以他们就在那里。但也有很多不同的团体参加了这些游行。
I mean, they weren't just women's groups either. They were, you know, fighting for immigrant rights and anti-racist. groups and you know, you name it. If it's on the progressive left, they went to that movement. So, you know, I think trying to sustain something at that scale is going to be really hard. If, you know, if the original marches that happened right after the inauguration, if they were dependent on people who were, who needed an immediate outlet and not totally made up of people who had this sophisticated political analysis, of course the movements are going to get smaller.
我的意思是，他们不仅仅是妇女团体。他们是，你知道，为移民权利而战，反种族主义团体，等等。如果是进步左派，他们就参加了那场运动。所以，你知道，我认为试图维持那种规模的运动会非常困难。如果，你知道，如果就职典礼后发生的最初游行，依赖于那些需要立即发泄出口的人，而不是完全由那些有这种复杂政治分析的人组成，那么运动当然会变小。
But I wouldn't say that these movements have disappeared. They haven't. They've just kind of taken more standard paths now. They're being filtered through organizations that have been created since the inauguration of Trump. So, you know, even the hashtag Me Too movement, you could argue that that's part of it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I could see that. There's a new poll out that shows a large majority of Americans. Seventy-four percent
但我不会说这些运动已经消失了。它们没有。它们只是采取了更标准的路径。它们正在通过特朗普就职以来创建的组织进行过滤。所以，你知道，即使是“我也是”（Me Too）运动，你也可以说那是它的一部分。是的，没错。是的。我能看出来。有一项新的民意调查显示，绝大多数美国人，74%
support the current protests and that more than two-thirds believe the killing of George Floyd wasn't an isolated incident. And this contrasts with 2014 when police killed unarmed black men in Ferguson, Missouri, when Michael Brown was killed in New York City, the case of Eric Garner. And back then, there was a poll that found 51 percent of Americans. thought those killings were isolated incidents. This seems like a big change in just six years. Now, I realize that polls are just a snapshot in time, but has public opinion really changed that much? Is that a big change over a short period of time? I, this is why I'm arguing this is a tipping point. I think this is this is what happened.
支持当前的抗议活动，超过三分之二的人认为乔治·弗洛伊德的被杀并非孤立事件。这与2014年形成了对比，当时警察在密苏里州弗格森杀害了手无寸铁的黑人，迈克尔·布朗被杀，以及在纽约市，埃里克·加纳的案件。当时，有一项民意调查发现51%的美国人认为这些杀戮是孤立事件。这在短短六年内似乎是一个巨大的变化。现在，我意识到民意调查只是一个时间点的快照，但公众舆论真的改变了这么多吗？在短时间内这是一个巨大的变化吗？我，这就是我为什么认为这是一个临界点的原因。我认为这就是发生了什么。
This is what happened with gay marriage. This is, you know, for a long time, you know, people were arguing that that non-straight people deserve the rights to get married, et cetera. And that went nowhere for years and years and years. And then there, you know, maybe it's generational replacement. You know, there's part part of the time it's, you know, younger generations getting to be voting age, whatever, you know, just or just a series of events that. that happen, that again, convince the, quote, silent majority that finally, like, no, we need to
这就是同性婚姻发生的情况。这是，你知道，很长一段时间以来，人们一直在争论非异性恋者应该有结婚的权利等等。这在多年来毫无进展。然后，你知道，也许是代际更替。你知道，部分原因是年轻一代到了投票年龄，等等，你知道，或者只是一系列事件，再次说服了所谓的“沉默的大多数”，最终，不，我们需要
actually speak up for these people's rights. So I would say that the polls that you just, the change in the polls that you just talk about is really encouraging. I'm really happy to hear that. And that to me, that's evidence of that things are, things may actually have a chance to change. I mean, we've seen in the newspapers recently, too, about how police departments across the U.S. are reconsidering their, some are talking about completely, the Minneapolis police department is talking about completely starting over with how they're going to police or how they're going to think about police. And that's, that is really what needs to happen. And that I've just been reading, you know, town after town is doing this. And so I'm feeling like this is, this is, this isn't. tipping point and that things hopefully will change now. So your work talks about how identity is related to collective action. Can you talk about what that means? Yes. So hundreds and hundreds of studies in psychology have shown that there are three components, three things that if you have them tend to be related to participation in collective action. And the first is identity. And identity means
实际上为这些人的权利大声疾呼。所以我认为你刚才谈到的民意调查的变化确实令人鼓舞。我很高兴听到这个消息。对我来说，这是事情可能真的有机会改变的证据。我的意思是，我们最近在报纸上也看到，美国各地的警察部门正在重新考虑他们的做法，有些人正在谈论彻底改变，明尼阿波利斯警察局正在谈论彻底重新开始他们将如何执法或如何思考警察问题。而这，确实是需要发生的事情。我一直在读，一个又一个城镇正在这样做。所以我感觉这是一个临界点，希望事情现在会改变。那么你的工作谈到了身份与集体行动的关系。你能谈谈这意味着什么吗？是的。心理学中成百上千的研究表明，有三个组成部分，如果你拥有这三样东西，往往与参与集体行动有关。第一个是身份。身份意味着
oftentimes when we've done research on this, we're usually talking about groups who haven't held a lot of power and influence in society. So, you know, African Americans, you might talk about versus whites, you might talk about, you know, women versus men, non-straight people versus straight people, the people who don't have a lot of power and influence in society. So those are called social identities, the kind of the group members. memberships. Everybody has a bunch of social identities that influence how they're treated in society and how they think of themselves. And everybody's got a unique combination of those sorts of social identities. And they tend to be, some tend to be privileged and some tend to be treated less well. And when we talk about collective action, we talk about identity. We're talking about organizing around subordinate group identities. So, So women, feminists identifying around their gender identity, African Americans organizing around their racial identity, et cetera. So most research on collective action has shown that when people identify with their social group and link their fate to the fate of other members of that group. So they don't just see themselves as individuals. They say something like the way.
通常当我们对此进行研究时，我们通常谈论的是在社会中没有掌握太多权力和影响力的群体。所以，你知道，非裔美国人，你可能会谈论与白人的对比，你可能会谈论女性与男性，非异性恋者与异性恋者，那些在社会中没有太多权力和影响力的人。所以这些被称为社会身份，即群体成员身份。每个人都有一堆社会身份，影响着他们在社会中如何被对待以及他们如何看待自己。每个人都有这些社会身份的独特组合。其中一些往往是特权阶层，而另一些往往受到较差的对待。当我们谈论集体行动时，我们谈论身份。我们谈论的是围绕从属群体身份进行组织。所以，女性，女权主义者围绕她们的性别身份进行认同，非裔美国人围绕她们的种族身份进行组织，等等。所以大多数关于集体行动的研究表明，当人们认同他们的社会群体并将他们的命运与该群体其他成员的命运联系起来时。所以他们不仅仅把自己看作个体。他们会说类似这样的话：
African Americans are treated in society is going to impact how I'm treated. The way I'm treated impacts other members of my group, et cetera. So if they have a sense of common fate, if they think that what happens to them will have an impact on other members of their group and vice versa, that tends to be their social identity. And that's the identity component. But you can identify with a social group, like you can identify as getting. without having a politicized identity. So the next part that you really need is a sense of injustice. So the idea that I'm a member of a particular social group and my group has been unfairly treated in society.
非裔美国人在社会中被对待的方式将影响我被对待的方式。我被对待的方式影响我群体的其他成员，等等。所以如果他们有一种共同命运感，如果他们认为发生在他们身上的事情会对他们群体的其他成员产生影响，反之亦然，那往往就是他们的社会身份。这就是身份组成部分。但你可以认同某个社会群体，比如你可以认同为同性恋，而没有政治化的身份。所以你真正需要的下一部分是“不公正感”。即：我是某个特定社会群体的成员，我的群体在社会中受到了不公平的对待。
We've been unfairly deprived of power and resources. We've been discriminated against. We've been treated with violence, et cetera. And it's not our fault. There's systemic reasons. And that's really the key. The key is to say to get away from these classic American meritocracy arguments, that the reason we haven't had a woman president yet is that just women aren't interested
我们被不公平地剥夺了权力和资源。我们受到了歧视。我们受到了暴力对待，等等。这不是我们的错。有系统性的原因。这才是关键。关键是要摆脱这些经典的美国精英管理论调，即我们还没有女总统的原因仅仅是因为女性不感兴趣
or women aren't good enough. It's because there's systemic sexism in our society. Or the reason that African Americans in Minneapolis are seven times as likely to be treated with violence by the police than white people is not because the African Americans in Minneapolis are seven times more violent. It's because there's systemic racism there. So once you have a systemic analysis and you get away from, it's, you know, the individual's fault. It's because there's some structural stuff going on. Then that becomes, that helps you politicize that particular identity. So there's identity, injustice, and then the other one is efficacy, which is basically a belief that you need to work together as a group to change things and that you have to believe
或者女性不够优秀。这是因为我们的社会存在系统性的性别歧视。或者明尼阿波利斯非裔美国人被警察暴力对待的可能性是白人的七倍，并不是因为明尼阿波利斯的非裔美国人暴力程度高出七倍。这是因为那里存在系统性的种族主义。所以一旦你有了系统性的分析，摆脱了“这是个人的错”的观点，因为存在一些结构性的东西。那么这就有助于你将那个特定的身份政治化。所以有身份、不公正，另一个是“效能感”，这基本上是一种信念，即你需要作为一个群体共同努力来改变事情，并且你必须相信
that your actions will make a difference. So that's how the three are related. And then when we talk about allies, for example, white people who are out on the streets protesting right now, you can think about expanding identity so that it isn't just that you're focusing on members of your group. For white people protesting right now, it could be that they have embraced an anti-racist identity, which is a very good identity for white people to embrace when they're going to do this sort of work. But it could also be that they've expanded their definition. definition of identity to think about all of humanity. So oftentimes you'll see religious groups when they do this sort of activism, they're talking about morality and they're talking about
你的行动会产生影响。这就是这三者之间的关系。然后当我们谈论盟友时，例如现在走上街头抗议的白人，你可以考虑扩大身份，这样你就不仅仅关注你群体的成员。对于现在抗议的白人来说，可能是他们拥抱了一种反种族主义身份，这对白人来说是一个非常好的身份，当他们要进行这种工作时。但也可能是他们扩大了身份的定义，去思考全人类。所以通常你会看到宗教团体在进行这种行动主义时，他们谈论的是道德，他们谈论的是
we are all human and they're not focused so much on their individual racial identity. They're talking more about all humanity. So there's two ways that works. Or even their individual religious identity, it's not like an Episcopal is marching for Episcopals. Right. Yeah. They're marching based on, you know, maybe some, maybe an identity that was helped, that was being formed or was helped in its formation by their religious beliefs or their beliefs. But the key identity there would be that I believe that there's no difference between
我们都是人类，他们并没有过多关注他们个人的种族身份。他们更多地谈论全人类。所以这有两种运作方式。甚至他们个人的宗教身份，并不是说圣公会教徒在为圣公会教徒游行。对。是的。他们游行是基于，你知道，也许是某种，也许是一种身份，这种身份的形成得到了他们的宗教信仰或信念的帮助。但那里的关键身份是，我相信任何种族的人类之间没有区别。而且会发生什么，这是一种共同命运感。发生在非裔美国人身上的事情对我作为一个有道德的人也有影响。所以只要你拥有一个能够拥抱类似东西的身份，那么这也可以成为行动主义的动力。通过历史视角以及心理学视角来看，有哪些因素往往使某些抗议运动更成功或更不成功？是的。
human beings of any racial group. And what happens, it's this sense of common fate. what happens to African Americans has an impact on me as a moral person as well. So as long as you have an identity that can embrace something like that, then that can also be motivating for activism. Looking through a historic lens as well as a psychological lens, are there factors that tend to make certain protest movements more or less successful? Yes.
这就是所谓的临界点论点和沉默的大多数论点。所以马丁·路德·金是一位非常出色的组织者。他帮助《民权法案》获得通过等所做的事情之一，就是他在与当地社区合作时非常有策略。所以民权运动已经进行了多年，人们一直在，非裔美国人一直在抗议不公平待遇和歧视
This is the kind of the tipping point argument. and the silent majority argument. So Martin Luther King was a, Martin Luther King Jr. was a pretty brilliant organizer. One of the things he did to help the Civil Rights Act get passed, et cetera, was he was very strategic when he was working with local communities. So the Civil Rights Movement had been going on for years and years and years and people had been, African Americans had been protesting unfair treatment and discrimination
以及种族隔离多年。但临界点出现在他和运动的其他领导人决定在他们知道有反动市长或某种政府领导人的城镇举行抗议活动时，他们知道警察会向他们喷射消防水龙，他们知道他们会受到暴力对待。所以他们会选择那些地方进行和平游行，而且必须是和平的，抗议者必须衣着得体，因为他们试图说服北方的沉默白人多数，他们理应像白人一样被对待。然后他们把媒体叫来。
and segregation for years. But the tipping point came when he and his other leaders of the movement decided to hold protests in towns where they knew that there was a reactionary mayor or some sort of government leader where they knew that the police would turn fire hoses on them, where they knew that they would be treated with violence. And so they would choose those sorts of places to do peaceful marches, and it had to be peaceful, and the protesters had to be well-dressed because they were trying to convince the silent white majority in the north that they deserve to be treated like white people. And then they called the media in.
所以当那些只是，你知道，坐在缅因州农舍里的某个人，打开报纸，在电视上看到这些看起来非常体面的非裔美国人做着非常和平的事情，却受到这种明显的、明显的无礼和明显的暴力对待时，那是一种方式。得到这些戏剧性的、你不可能认为这是可以的图像。一旦你做到了这一点，那么就更容易了，这就是临界点到来的时刻，当这个，我的意思是，这是有助于创造这个临界点的因素之一，就是当你拥有这些清晰的对比时。什么是对的，什么是错的，一目了然。所以向人们放出狗或向他们喷射消防水龙是令人震惊的。是的，没错。所以坐在缅因州农舍里的某个人以前从未见过这种情况。
And so when people who were just kind of, you know, somebody sitting up in their farmhouse in Maine, opened the newspaper and saw on TV these images of these very respectable looking African Americans doing something very peaceful, but getting treated with this obvious, obvious disrespect and obvious violence, then that was a way. getting these kind of dramatic, there's no way you could think that this was okay, kind of image. Once you did that, then it was easier to, that's when the tipping point comes, is when this, I mean, that's one of the factors that can help create this tipping point is when you have these clear contrasts. And it's easy what's right and what's wrong. So setting dogs on people or turning the fire hoses on them was shocking. Yes, exactly. So somebody sitting in their farmhouse in Maine has never seen that before.
而且，你知道，你可以随心所欲地在报纸上读到它。但当你看到图像时，图像只是，我的意思是，人类天生就会对视觉图像做出反应。所以当你看到它或听到它，或者两者兼有时，它就更有可能帮助创造那种促使那些拥有特权、不需要做任何事情的人采取行动的东西。然而，在越南战争抗议期间也有可怕的图像，但我知道我当时还活着，当然我知道正在发生什么，你会听到人们说，嗯，那些肮脏的嬉皮士，他们活该。对。
And, you know, you can read about it in the paper all you want. But when you see the image, the images are just, I mean, human beings are wired to respond to visual images. And so when you see it or you hear it or both, it's just much more likely to help create that thing that gets people who have privilege who don't, quote, have to do anything. things spurs them into action. And yet there were frightful images during the Vietnam War protests, but I know I was alive at the time, and certainly I was aware of what was happening, that you would hear people saying, well, those dirty hippies, they deserve it. Right.
我的意思是，这与60年代非裔美国人所做的事情有什么对比？嗯，所以这非常有趣。人类似乎有一种将人分为“我们”与“他们”的自然倾向。所以，如果你是从属群体的一部分，并且你想让所谓的“沉默的大多数”站在你这边，那么你可以采取的方法之一就是让沉默的大多数将你的群体视为他们中的一员。所以我刚才给你的那个关于和平民权运动抗议的例子，他们说你需要穿上你最好的周日服装，你需要有礼貌，你需要，我的意思是，这很荒谬。
I mean, how is that, how does that contrast with what African American people did in the 60s? Well, so it's very interesting. human beings are seem to have this natural tendency to group people into us versus them. And so one of the ways that you can get, if you're part of a subordinate group and you want to get the quote silent majority on your side is you want to get the silent majority to see your group as one of them. So this example that I was giving you with the peaceful civil rights movement protests, where they said you need to dress in your Sunday best, you need to be polite, you need to, I mean, it's ridiculous.
你根本不应该做任何这些事情。对。但这是一种策略，这样北方的白人，特别是，会看着这些人并看到这些说，这些人和我一模一样。也许他们的皮肤稍微黑一点，但他们和我一模一样。所以当你谈论“肮脏的嬉皮士”，所谓的“肮脏的嬉皮士”，其中大多数是白人，他们没有那种整体。所以特别是，你知道，大学生，白人大学生，婴儿潮一代的一部分，他们抗议越南战争。他们大多来自中产阶级背景，白人背景。
You shouldn't have to do any of that. Right. But this was a tactic used so that white people in the north in particular would look at these people and see these say, these people are exactly like me. Maybe their skin's a little bit darker, but they're exactly like me. So when you're talking about dirty hippies, quote, dirty hippies, most of whom were white, they didn't have that whole. So especially, you know, college students, white college students, part of the baby boom who were protesting Vietnam. They were from mostly from middle class backgrounds, white backgrounds.
他们没有那种知道当你出去抗议时，你是在试图说服所谓的“沉默的大多数”的全部遗产。所以你需要向他们和他们的保守主义呼吁，对吧？这些孩子就像是，嘿，我要做我想做的事，这是错的，他们会听我的。所以我认为这就是区别。所以这有道理吗？是的，完全有道理。我的意思是，因为我记得LGBT权利运动也有类似的事情，当时会有像纽约的克里斯托弗街游行。一个派系会说，哦，天哪，这些人全都赤身裸体，这太可怕了。
They didn't have a whole legacy of knowing that when you go out and you protest that you're trying to convince the, quote, silent majority. And so you need to appeal to them and their conservatism, right? These were kids who were like, hey, I'm going to do what I want and this is wrong and they're going to listen to me. And so I think that's the difference. And so does that make sense? Yeah, totally. I mean, because I remember similar things with LGBT rights movement where there would be like the Christopher Street March in New York. And one faction would say, oh, my God, all of these people are naked and this is horrible.
另一个派系会说，但这正是我们的身份，我们不会改变。对。我并不是说做这些事情有正确的方法或错误的方法。我认为很多——大多数运动都有多个分支和不同的组成部分。以及参与其中的不同的人，他们可能需要所有这些。而且，你知道，对于一些人，你知道，那些认同同性恋权利运动
And another faction would say, but this is our identity and we're not going to change. Right. And I'm not arguing that there's a right way or a wrong way to do any of these things. I think a lot of – most movements have multiple strands and different constituent. and different people who participate, and they probably need all of them. And, you know, for some people, you know, who are identifying with the gay rights movement
并且想要为同性恋者的权利而战的人，展示那些，你知道，完全华丽的同性恋男人，或者赤身裸体的人，或者其他什么，真的很重要。这对于让一定比例的公众加入非常重要。但你也有，你也有，如果你谈论的是试图说服所谓的“沉默的大多数”，你是在试图，
and who want to fight for the rights of gay people, it's really important to show the, you know, the totally flamboyant gay man out there or naked people or whatever. That was really important to get some percentage of the public on board. But there's also, you, also, if you're talking about trying to convince the quote silent majority, you're trying to,
首先，你是在试图以一种你并没有太多信息的方式来定义它。但你是在试图向各种各样的人呼吁。所以我认为大多数运动需要不同类型的人，一系列不同类型的策略和人才能成功。如果他们拥有一个范围，他们往往会更成功。那么一个人对社会运动有多重要？我的意思是，一个运动是否需要甘地、罗莎·帕克斯或莱奎恩扎才能更快地成功？嗯，关于罗莎·帕克斯，有趣的是，当然，她多年来一直在进行抗议运动。而且她被战略性地选择成为一个象征。所以，我认为这就是重点，对吧，就是个人有时会成为象征或领袖，仅仅是因为他们恰好在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。但有时他们被运动战略性地选择来促成特定的反应
first of all, you're trying to define that in a way where you don't really have very much information. But you're trying to appeal to all sorts of people. And so I think most movements need different types of people, a range of different types of tactics and people to be successful. And they tend to be more successful if they've got a range. So how important is one individual to a social movement? I mean, does a movement need a Gandhi or Rosa Parks or Lequellenza to succeed more quickly? Well, and the interesting thing about Rosa Parks, of course, is that she had been doing protest movements for years and years. And she was strategically chosen to be a symbol to. And so that, I think that is the point, right, is that individuals are sometimes, become symbols or figureheads just kind of because they happen to be in the right place at the right time. But sometimes they're strategically chosen by movements to to spur a particular reaction
或者，你知道，我的意思是，她被选中抗议公交车上的种族隔离，因为谁，再次，沉默的大多数，如果他们看到这个看起来无害的小老太太在公交车上，而且她在漫长的一天工作后如此疲惫，谁能说，是的，她需要去坐在后面，你知道？所以有时这是战略性的。我的意思是，你知道，人们，当你谈论领导者时，有些人很有魅力。
or, you know, I mean, she was chosen to protest the segregation on the bus because who, again, the silent majority, if they see this kind of harmless looking little old lady on a bus and and she's so tired after her long day work, like who could ever say that, yeah, she needs to go sit in the back, you know? So sometimes it's strategic. I mean, you know, people, when you talk about leaders, some people are charismatic.
他们倾向于以正确的方式说出在特定时间需要被听到的事情。所以毫无疑问，个人很重要。有时是因为战略原因，但有时是因为他们恰好是在正确的时间说正确话的正确人选。让我们稍微换个话题，谈谈家庭参与政治行动的作用。是的。例如，反战示威者的孩子，他们今天成为活动家的可能性更大吗？这可能会产生什么影响
They tend to say things in the right way that happens to correspond with what needs to be heard at a particular time. So definitely their individuals are important. sometimes for strategic reasons, but sometimes because they just happen to be the right person saying the right thing at the right time. Let's change tracks here a little bit and talk about the role of family involvement in political activism. Yes. Are children of anti-war demonstrators, for example, are they any more likely to become activists today? And what might be the impact
对现在被带去参加抗议的孩子们？哦，绝对。所以是的，心理学研究已经显示了代际影响。所以我的研究表明，当我们谈论1991年反对海湾战争的抗议活动时，我当时在密歇根大学，就在布什总统，第一任布什总统，决定是否入侵伊拉克的时候，我的意思是，科威特。所以无论如何，我们发现的是，孩子们，也就是那些父母曾抗议过越南战争的大学生，更有可能抗议海湾战争。那些父母曾参加过越南战争或支持越南战争的孩子的孩子，更有可能站在“支持我们的军队”一边。有趣的是，那些父母对越南战争没有任何反应、没有积极反应的孩子，也更有可能
on kids who are being taken to protest right now? Oh, absolutely. So yeah, the research and psychology has shown generational impact. So my own research showed that when we're talking about the protests against the Gulf War in 1991, I was at University of Michigan at that point and right around the time when President Bush, the first President Bush, was deciding whether or not to invade Iraq or not, I mean, Kuwait. So anyway, what we found was that, that kids, so college students who had parents who had protested the Vietnam War were much more likely to protest the Gulf War. Kids who had parents who had either fought in Vietnam or were pro-Vietnam supporters were more likely to be on the support our troop side. And interestingly, kids who had parents who didn't have any sort of reaction to the Vietnam War, active reaction, were also more likely to,
在海湾战争中什么都不做。所以，这只是研究的一个例子。已经有许多研究表明，父母为孩子塑造行为。他们塑造你如何解决政治问题？你如何对政治问题做出反应？所以当父母现在带着孩子参加这些抗议活动时，这很可能会成为孩子们成年后看待事物方式的一部分。这是你可以做的事情之一。
to not do anything in response to the Gulf War. So, and this is just one example of a study. There have been many studies that show that parents model behavior for children. They model how do you solve political problems? How do you react to political problems? So when parents are taking children right now to these protests, it will probably become just a part of how children see when they become adults. This is one of the things you can do.
如果你看到不公正的事情，这是你抗议工具箱里的一个工具。而且不仅仅是行为，对吧？他们当时也在学习特定的态度。所以，是的。所以我想在这里提出两点。一是无论你的父母作为孩子为你塑造什么，都会成为你默认的看待事物的方式。这就是我处理事情的方式。但当我们谈论年轻人时，年轻人正处于身份发展的阶段。他们试图弄清楚他们是谁，他们在这个世界上的位置，他们相信什么。他们可能会质疑父母教给他们的东西。
This is a tool you have in your protests. toolbox if you see something unjust. And it's not just the behavior, right? They're also learning particular attitudes, too, at the time. So, yeah. So I would say there's two points I want to make here. One is that whatever your parents are modeling for you as a child becomes your default for kind of the way you're just going to see. This is how I deal with things in general. But when we're talking about young adults, young adults are in identity development. They're trying to figure out who they are, where they fit into the world, what they believe in. They may be questioning what their parents have taught them.
这与他们现在的信仰一致吗？他们试图以这种方式弄清楚承诺。所以大量研究也表明，当你年轻时发生的任何事情，都会对你如何看待自己产生持久的影响，即使在多年后也是如此。我们拥有的经典例子是那些反对越南战争或支持越南战争的抗议者，婴儿潮一代，他们甚至在多年后作为70岁的老人，可能最终将自己定义为60年代的激进分子。所以是的，这些现在正在发生的事件可能会产生巨大的影响。对于未来几周和几个月我们应该期待看到什么，有什么想法吗？这场抗议有后劲吗？你能看出来吗？
Is it consistent with what they believe now? They're trying to figure out commitments in that way. So lots and lots of research has also shown that whatever's happening when you're a young adult is going to have a long-lasting impact on how you see yourself even many, many years. later. And the classic example we have of that are these protesters against Vietnam or Vietnam War supporters, baby boomers in general, that may end up defining themselves even many years later as 70-year-olds as kind of 60 radicals, 60s radicals. So yeah, so these events that are going on right now can have a huge impact. Any thoughts on what we should expect to see in the coming weeks and months? Does this protest have legs? Can you tell yet?
嗯，你知道，仅仅是我在报纸上读到关于警察部门在我自己的城镇，我所在的北安普顿小镇做出改变的事实，他们已经有了，我们已经有了带有公众评论的在线市政厅会议，最后一次。所以我想它通常应该只是几个小时。第一次是六个小时。哇。然后就像午夜一样。他们几天后不得不增加另一场会议。那是八个小时。所以，而且绝大多数，你知道，有数百人，我这个3万人的小镇，数百人参加了Zoom会议，基本上在谈论，你知道，削减警察部门的资金等等。
Well, you know, just the fact that I'm reading in the paper about police departments making changes in my own town, my small town of Northampton here, they've had, we've had online city hall meetings with the public commentary and the last one. So I think it's usually supposed to be just a couple of hours. The first one was six hours. Wow. And then it was like midnight. They had to add another meeting a couple days later. And that was eight hours. So and the vast, you know, there are hundreds of people, my town of 30,000, hundreds of people who were getting onto the Zoom meeting and basically talking about, you know, cutting funding to the police department, et cetera.
所以我，你知道，你在美国各地的社区都看到了这一点。所以我认为这有后劲。我认为人们通过社交媒体组织起来的事实可以有后劲。我的意思是，我绝对认为那里有，这适用于任何运动，而且这些天更容易，因为事情在社交媒体上被宣传或呈现的方式。人们很容易在一天或两天内加入，然后退出。这超级容易。他们称之为，你知道，那可能是“点击主义”。这是我们使用的术语之一，就是你只是点个赞，就这样了。
So I, you know, you're seeing that in communities all across the United States. So I think that has legs. I think that the fact that people have organized over social media can have legs. I mean, I definitely think there, and this is true of any movement, and it's easier these days because of the way things are advertised on social media or presented on social media. It's very easy for people to kind of drop in for a day or two and then drop out. That's super easy. And they call it that, you know, that can be clickivism. That's one of the terms that we use is you just click a like and that's it.
所以，你知道，你在美国各地的社区都看到了这一点。所以我认为这很有潜力。我认为人们通过社交媒体进行组织这一事实也很有潜力。我的意思是，我绝对认为，任何运动都是如此，而且由于社交媒体上广告或呈现事物的方式，现在变得更容易了。人们很容易参与一两天然后退出。这非常容易。他们称之为，你知道，那可能是“点击主义”。这是我们使用的术语之一，就是你只是点个赞，仅此而已。
But, you know, so some percentage of people will just end up dropping out of it altogether. But this will have an impact and, you know, some percentage of people will continue with this. So I personally see this as a tipping point. I think there is going to be more. sustained commitment to this, especially with younger people. And the other thing is, as long as it's really important for people who start participating in activism to get connected to a community and to make friends and to feel support because it's really hard to be angry all the time.
但是，你知道，会有一定比例的人最终完全退出。但这会产生影响，而且，你知道，会有一定比例的人坚持下去。所以我个人认为这是一个转折点。我认为未来会有更多人对此做出持续的承诺，尤其是年轻人。另一件事是，对于开始参与行动主义的人来说，与社区建立联系、结交朋友并感受到支持非常重要，因为一直处于愤怒状态真的很难。
And so they need to find ways to connect in with an organization or a group. that has learned how to manage the emotional toll that it takes on people to do this sort of thing. This is not easy work for anyone. All right. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Duncan, and for sharing your insights into these challenging times we're experiencing. My pleasure. The American Psychological Association has information and resources on our website regarding racism and disparities, along with techniques for coping and minimizing the stress and anxiety
因此，他们需要找到与组织或团体建立联系的方法，这些组织或团体已经学会了如何管理这种工作给人们带来的情感负担。这对任何人来说都不是容易的工作。好的，邓肯博士，感谢您今天加入我们，并分享您对我们所经历的这些充满挑战的时代的见解。这是我的荣幸。美国心理学会的网站上有关于种族主义和差异的信息和资源，以及应对和减少压力与焦虑的技巧。
you might be experiencing right now. So visit us at APA.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeckycology.org. And you can subscribe to our podcast on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And while you're there, please give us a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts,
您现在可能正在经历这些。所以请访问我们的网站 APA.org。您还可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。您可以在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方订阅我们的播客。在您收听的同时，请给我们评分。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，
email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman, Our editor and sound engineer is Chris Kondayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作，我们的编辑和音响工程师是克里斯·孔达扬。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。